hey guys it's max today we're comparing
Samsung's latest flagship phone the s20
ultra against their previous flagship
the note 10 plus now I'm very curious
about this because I want to see how big
of a difference is there really how much
more are you gaining paying $1,400 for
the s20 ultra compared to now being able
to buy the note 10 plus for as low as
the 650 dollars on Amazon which is
shockingly low I'll go ahead and leave a
link to that down in the video
description now I've just spent a week
using the s20 ultra as my main phone and
it's very interesting to pick up the
note 10 plus after a long while there is
a massive difference of feeling in the
hand
now I thought the note 10 plus was a
fairly large phone but when you hold the
side-by-side not only is the s20 ultra
kind of a little bit taller but the
feeling of the hand is crazy this feels
like a phone from 3-4 years ago it is
much thicker where this feels like a
really thin slate in comparison and you
guys can see that just in the body alone
but then when you put the camera bump
side-by-side man this thing is massive
now there's only about 24 grams
difference in weight but holding him in
the hand it is a massive difference and
I have to say the note 10 plus is
definitely a lot more comfortable but
what that said the s20 ultra even though
it's taller and has a larger screen it's
actually slightly narrower which makes
it a little bit easier to grip in the
hand but it's not by that much now as
far as controls the note n plus has all
the controls on the left hand side here
whereas s22 ultra it has all the
controls on the right hand side and
being right-handed I much prefer that
now let's take a closer look at those
camera bumps and it is hilarious to see
the difference in just six months six
months ago look like Samsung was trying
to hide the camera bump it is very
mental barely sticks out it is so
minimalistic and then with s20 ultra it
is massive they're taking it to the max
and you could tell at least it seems
like they're taking cameras much more
seriously now we're gonna talk about
cameras a little bit more in just a bit
now I've never been somebody that was
really annoyed by camera bumps until I
got my hands on this phone it sticks out
so much that the phone does not lay flat
on the table if you guys see right here
this one barely rocks if at all whereas
this one it doesn't sit straight this
end is higher than this end and if you
press down look at that it is just
really funny and the s20 ultra is the
first phone in many years that actually
have to use a case with because this
ends up cutting into my fingers and then
I keep touching it so I end up making it
even thicker and even heavier whereas
with the note 10 plus I don't have to do
that apart from the buttons being on the
right hand side there's one more
physical difference that I really like
about the s20 and that's the fact that
the screen is barely curved over the
edges it's almost not noticeable kind of
like maybe an iPhone just slightly more
than that whereas the note 10 plus has a
much more extreme kind of curve not as
much as the s10 so Samsung is slowly
kind of going away from that trend and
I'm really happy because that minimises
glare and I feel like it's more
comfortable overall so that is a good
improvement now I've been very impressed
with the in display fingerprint scanner
the s20 ultra it's been very quick and
very consistent so let's compare it to
the note 10 pluses so as you guys see it
was just slightly faster there with s 20
a lot faster there with the screen being
turned off big difference so very
interesting it for somebody that likes
to turn on your phone when the screen is
off the s20 ultra is definitely faster
as you guys can tell but if you turn on
your screen first it's about the same no
I do like that the note tent is a little
bit more boxy and it's design which
includes the edges of the display and
set a more curved and the s20 ultra
screen is just a tiny bit larger as you
guys can see and the resolution on the
tall end is actually slightly higher to
accompany that now if we switch to 1080p
mode the s20 ultra gives us one feature
that we don't have on the no 10 and that
is the high refresh rate 120 Hertz
instead of 60 now this makes a really
big difference when you're going through
when you're scrolling through websites
when you're opening apps along with
these faster animations it is just
really really nice and smooth and
putting these side-by-side it's a big
difference now it's hard to show you
guys this on video with standard front
fresh rates so here's a shot with slow
motion so you guys can see the
difference for yourself 120 Hertz is
also really nice if you're into playing
games there are a number of games now
that support it and more to come out so
that does give it some advantage
especially if you play competitively and
in order to have that 120 Hertz we also
need a larger battery so the s20 ultra
has a massive 5,000 milliamp hour
battery compared to 4300 on the note 10
plus but even though it has a larger
battery the real-world battery life is
worse by about one hour in screen on
time if you're using that mode but
default out of the box it is set to
sixty Hertz and what 60 Hertz the
battery life will actually be slightly
better on the s20 ultra now the note 10
does have its own special feature that
it includes instead of us 120 Hertz
screen we have the Samsung S Pen now to
be completely honest I have never really
gotten into the s-pen how to use it for
maybe the first week or so and then just
keep it in the slot but for those of
people that are into it you have a bunch
of extra features and different
productivity tasks that you can do with
this you could draw you could take notes
it can recognize and turn that into text
and I know a lot of people out there
really enjoy using the s-pen so that is
what the note 10 offers the s20 ultra
seems to be using newer display tag but
when he max out the brightness it is
almost identical and the note 10 plus
actually might be just a little bit
brighter but if we look at the off-axis
shift the s20 holds its brightness just
slightly more and also doesn't get as
blue when we look from the side but it
is also very close now both of these
phones can play back at 1440p 60fps with
HDR and youtube which is awesome it
looks fantastic they both look good but
i did notice a difference the new s20
ultra actually does a better job the
highlights over here get brighter or on
this side and then the colors pop a
little bit more and it makes the overall
HDR experience look better it is clearly
noticeable and it's the best HDR video I
have ever seen on a smartphone these
phones get so bright that I had to turn
that camera above
way down for you guys to be able to see
all the highlights and it makes
everything look dark because this video
isn't in HDR but both these look great
so the s20 ultra does provide a better
video experience but how about audio
let's go ahead and get into our speaker
comparison I have Dolby Atmos turned on
with both and you guys will let me know
down in the comments section which one
you think sounds better make sure to
wear a good pair of headphones and I'll
give you guys my opinion let's get
started
[Music]
[Music]
the s20 ultra is definitely louder it is
substantial and that will come in handy
if you're listening to you know videos
music and a loud room sharing stuff and
especially if the content you're
listening to is quieter than normal
I really had liked having the extra
volume but something else was
interesting that I was not expecting and
that is that the note n plus does sound
better in terms of sound quality at
first I thought it was just because it
was quieter maybe Samsung is just taking
the same speakers and pushing them
louder to make it sound worse but then I
turned it down by about two clicks and
that made it about the same volume level
but the note n+ still sounded better the
highs are a little bit more clear the
mid sounded a little bit smoother so if
you care about sound quality the note n
plus is the better way to go but
personally I would choose the louder
speakers now it's time to get into
performance both these phones use
Snapdragon processors but new s20 ultra
uses the 865 compared to the 855 both
are eight cores and the frequencies
actually line up very similarly so let's
test out the CPU and see what kind of
difference we have and as we expected
the s20 ultra is more powerful but it's
also interesting is that both the single
core performance and the multi-core
performance is right at 22 percent more
powerful usually it's not evenly
balanced so yes the CPU is more powerful
now how about the graphics let's test
that out and it looks like the adrenal
650 in the s20 is about 40% more
powerful than the 640 in the note 10
plus now you have to say that for most
things you're gonna do you will not
notice a difference and even in most
games because this graphics card is
already more than enough and a lot of
games aren't pushing the graphics that
much but with that said if you're
playing at 120 Hertz you definitely want
that extra performance and it's also
more future-proof now let's talk about
another category of performance but this
time it's going to be LTE speeds the
note 10 plus is not a slouch it's modem
is about twice as fast as the the best
iPhone available but all the new as 20s
have 5g built in and here you guys can
see the speed difference is when I
popped my sim in we have 20 2.7 megabit
per second download compared to 70 8.2
that's a massive difference now I'm
using t-mobile which mainly
as the sub 6 5g and that helps penetrate
buildings better into basements and also
gives you some faster speeds and you
guys can see here that makes a pretty
massive difference and I've seen up to
162 megabit per second with s20 ultra so
as far as performance that's when the
ultra definitely is better but that's
only if your carrier supports it it also
depends on what city you're in and if
you're somebody that wants a note 10
with 5g you do have the option as well
but it does cost a lot more than the
best deals you can get for the standard
version all right guys now it's time to
talk about the cameras and this is where
it gets very interesting now with the
s20 ultra Samsung is using their own
Samsung sensors instead of with the note
and the previous Samsung flagship they
always use Sony sensors because they
weren't the best on the market
comparing the front-facing cameras we
have 10 megapixels here compared to 40
that is a massive difference and then if
we flip over to the back and we compare
the main lenses here we have a 108
megapixel sensor on the s20 ultra
compared to a 12 with the telephoto we
also have a 12 megapixel two time zoom
compared to a 48 megapixel four times
optical zoom that can go up to 108 times
with their hybrid space zoom technology
that they Carla of course that looks
terrible but it does you know give you
better results than using something like
this and then with ultra wide it
actually flips this time we have 16
megapixels compared to 12 now there is
so much to test out so much positives
and negatives with this new camera stuff
like autofocus night modes actual
bending so we're gonna make a separate
video where we are not only going to
compare these two phones but also throw
in the s20 plus into the mix that also
uses sony sensors to see how much of a
difference is there really is it worth
dealing with such a huge camera bump in
actual real-world shots in real world
examples so make sure you guys click
Subscribe enable notifications so you
guys don't miss out on that video and
now let's see which one of these phones
is worth it let's talk about prices the
no 10 plus retailed at $1,100 when it
launched versus $1,400 for the s20 ultra
5g now if you wanted to get the 5
version of this it was $1,300 and keep
in mind there is a difference in storage
by about double with the no 10 plus 70
256 gig now at this time we have much
lower prices and as I mentioned at the
start you can get a no ten plus for as
low as 650 dollars on Amazon of course
that is a renewed model and I'll link it
down below but if you're willing to
spend maybe another 150 200 bucks you
can get a new one
so I usually don't wrap these up until
you guys which one I would buy in a lot
of cases but in this scenario I have to
say that I would choose the note 10 plus
now there are things that I love about
this phone
I love the 120 Hertz I love the louder
speakers I love the HDR and I really
like the 5 G that is built into here but
personally holding both these in the
hand there is just something that is so
nice feeling about this phone the fact
that it's much slimmer and much thinner
the camera bump doesn't stick out and I
know that this phone takes great images
and it's very consistent whereas this
one hasn't been as consistent it has its
issues at this time so because of all of
those things and once we count for the
price differences I would say I would
personally go with the note 10 plus now
you guys let me know your thoughts down
in the comment section below which one
of these would you choose and why make
sure you guys click that circle above to
subscribe and if you want to see a
couple great videos on that 20 ultra
click right over there this has been max
and I will see you in the next video
[Music]